dans le garden gens n'en a pas mais
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le secrétaire général
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
conseil de sécurité et
participants à cette réunion
je suis
content d avoir je me suis rendue à
bastia
et je me suis rendu compte que
nos forces militaires vancomycine on a
le crime
ils ont tué des femmes
se trouvaient
à l'extérieur de leur maison qui
appelait tellement ils ont essayé de
brûler les corps je m'adresse à vous au
nom
de ceux qui
sont morts
il faut deux villes qui ont décrit des
balles dans le dos certains d'entre eux
ont été tués dans la rue d'autres ont
été jetés au fond dans ce film ils ont
été tués dans leur appartement dans leur
maison
des grenades leur ont été jetés des
civils ont également été tués dans leur
voiture
alors tenté de fuir
les femmes ont été violées devant leurs
enfants
on à décapiter certaines personnes
tout simplement parce
ces personnes ni refusé de dire ce que
les forces russes voulaient entendre
et tout cet été par un membre du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies
et des prix les frontières d'un pays et
son unité
qui prive de ses droits une population
en détruisant la diversité de ce pays
l'objectif est de tuer le plus grand
nombre possible de civils
trop peu goûté foyers dans des villes où
l'on finit par découvrir des fosses
communes
il souhaite exporter cela dans d'autres
pays
grâce à un système de corruption et de
propagande une crise alimentaire
mondiale est également provoqué pour
déboucher sur la famine en afrique en
asie et ailleurs
et qui pourrait semer le chaos
aux quatre coins du monde détruisant la
sécurité de ces pays
le conseil de sécurité
existent
pour maintenir la sécurité
mais où est la paix aujourd'hui où sont
les garantes si que le conseil de 7 et
les nations unies sont censés apporter
il est évident que c'est une institution
qui ne boit
pas répondre à ces situations mais n'a
pas fonctionné normalement
ma blonde avant aujourd'hui ce que les
russes ont fait ali putsch à zurich sous
l'occupation mais le monde n'a pas
encore plus ce que les russes ont fait
dans d'autres villes régions occupées de
votre pays la géographie
mais la cruauté les crimes sont les
mêmes
et les coupables doivent rendre des
comptes
mesdames et messieurs je souhaiterais
vous rappeler l'article signé
la charte quel est le but de notre
organisation
il s'agit de
préserver la paix
mais aujourd'hui la charte est bafouée à
commencer par cet article 1er
aujourd'hui à la suite de l'action russe
l'action menée par les russes dans notre
pays
les crimes les plus
horribles sont perpétrés dans notre pays
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale les
troupes russes
détruisent délibérément des villes
entières en ukraine
par leurs frappes aériennes et leurs
tirs d'artillerie il affame des
populations et
10 ip convoi des civils qui cherchent à
fuir les hostilités ils ont même
et se tait des abris délibérément
dans les territoires occupés les villes
sont tus en grand nombre et le massacre
abrite chat
n'est qu'un exemple de ce que les forces
d'occupation
ayé c'est sur notre territoire ces
dernières semaines il y à d'autres
villes aussi
nous ne savons pas encore exactement ce
qui s'est passé mario de paul tchernihiv
karkhiv et d'autres communes evil
dont chacune a connu le même sort que
butch à
je sais très bien ce que dira le
représentant de la fédération de russie
en réponse à ces accusations
ils ont déjà dit à maintes reprises
notamment après
avoir abattu l'avion de la malaisienne
air lines ou pendant la guerre en syrie
ils pointent du doigt
n'importe qui pour justifier leur action
ils vous diront qu'il ya
différentes versions et que l'on ne peut
pas savoir laquelle de ces versions
représente la réalité
ils diront que s'agit d'une mise en
scène
mais nous avons des preuves irréfutables
des images satellitaires et nous pouvons
mener des enquêtes transparentes
c'est ce que nous souhaitons en
permettant l'accès
à ces informations aux journalistes avec
la participation de la cour pénale
internationale afin que les
responsabilités soient établies avec
certitude et je suis sûr que tous les
membres des nations unies souhaitent
connaître la vérité pourquoi et bien
pour punir une bonne pas pour tout ceux
qui s'estiment au dessus de tout
et pense pouvoir
commettre de tels crimes en toute
impunité il faut il montrer au monde
qu'ils peuvent être punis si les plus
puissants sont punis et bien il
sera possible de finir tous les autres
aussi alors pourquoi
la russie est en ukraine et bien parce
que eux se souhaite s'emparer de nos
richesses de notre population nous
coloniser des centaines de milliers de
personnes ont déjà été déporté en
baissier
de 2000 enfants été enlevée c'est les
enfants continuent d'être enlevé tous
les jours à la vessie veut que l'ukraine
tombons esclavage les villes et les
villages sont piller systématiquement
après avoir été capturés
les forces russes veulent tous
qu'elles peuvent donner de la nourriture
et tout le reste
alors que le renard sont couvertes de
sang
le droit de les taux devient en droit de
tuer
qui leur permet de commettre ses crimes
en toute impunité détruisent tout ce
qu'ils peuvent dans notre pays
si cette situation devait se poursuivre
est bien
on ne pourra dépendre que des armes pour
assurer notre sécurité on ne pourra peut
dépendre et des institutions
internationales
le prix
renoncer au droit international au rôle
de l'organisation des nations unies si
tel n'est pas le cas et bien il faut
agir immédiatement
la charte des nations unies du toulois
d'être rétabli le système des nations
unies doit être réformé pour que le
droit de veto ne doivent que viennent
ils ne soient pas en droit de le tuer
l'agresseur du bois rendre des comptes
immédiatement
les massacres commis en syrie en somalie
en afghanistan au yémen et en libye
aurait dû
être arrêtée il ya longtemps
s'il y avait eu une réponse adéquate à
la tyrannie par le passé
on aurait peut-être venir un terme à ces
agissements et le monde aurait changé
aujourd'hui la guerre fait rage dans
notre pays en ukraine le monde
a fermé les yeux sur l'inculpation de la
cride et sur la guerre menée contre la
géorgie sur
la situation en transnistrie
la russie
d'avoir d'autres conflits à ses
frontières alors comment arrêter cela
des forces militaires
russes
et ceux qui donnent des ordres
à ses fils doivent être arrêtés tous
ceux qui ont donné les ordres criminels
doivent rendre des comptes
et jugé par un tribunal
comme celui de nurenberg je rappelle aux
diplomates russes
aux crimes
de parpaings n'ont plus
aucun de ces criminels n'a échappé aux
sanctions et à la punition
aujourd'hui il est temps que les nations
unies fassent de même je propose tant
que l'on convoqué une conférence
internationale
ici à kiev pour déterminer comment nous
souhaitons réformer le système
sécuritaire mondiale
en établissant des garanties de
reconnaissance des frontières afin
d'assurer l'intégrité des états
et faire respecter le droit
international
les objectifs fixés en 1945 à san
francisco pour la création
d'une sécurité globales n'ont pas été
atteints il est impossible d'atteindre
ses objectifs sans réformer le système
international c'est pourquoi nous devons
faire tout ce qui est en notre pouvoir
afin que l'onu puisse servir les
générations futures qu'elles soient en
mesure de réagir aux enjeux de sécurité
prévenir l'agression et forcer les
agressions à faire la paix
le nude doit pouvoir punir ceux qui
bafoue les principes de la paix
il ne peut y avoir d'exception et de
privilèges tous doivent
participer à l'ordre international sur
un pied d'égalité quelles que soient
leurs ambitions leur emplacement
géographique
le pouvoir de la paix doit prévaloir le
pouvoir de la justice de la sécurité
comme l'humanité on a toujours rêvé et
l'ukraine est prête à accueillir
des bureaux de ce nouveau système comme
le bureau chargé des droits de l'homme à
genève le celui de neil rouby
une innovation de spécialisé dans les
mesures préventives de protection de
l'apd et je souhaiterais voir rappeler
notre mission en afghanistan une mission
de paix nous avons évacué l'eau de
milliers de personnes non
c'était une défense très difficile
mais l'ukraine a accueilli
des personnes de différentes
nationalités et nuit
nous l'avons fait sans discrimination
choisi il fallait des à chaque fois
qu'une personne avait besoin des deux
nous avons tendu la main
s'était montré la même chose le monde
serait beaucoup plus sûres
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui nous
proposons des réformes du système de
sécurité mondiale nous avons prouvé que
nous étions capables d'aider dans les
moments les plus sombres
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin que le
conseil de sécurité prenne une décision
en faveur de la paix
si vous ne savez pas comment faire vous
pouvez soit
éliminé la russie en tant qu'agresseur
un temps de
2h de guerre afin que la russie ne
puisse pas bloquer des décisions qui
concernent sa propre guerre et son
agression
et ensuite
et on pourra commencer à faire la paix
l'autre option serait de montrer comment
nous pouvons déformé modifier ou
le système de sécurité et evry à la paix
si rien de tout cela n'est possible
la seule option serait
de 10 ou drogue le concert nous avons
besoin de paix aujourd'hui l'europe a
besoin de paix le monde a besoin de la
paix et enfin
j'aimerais vous demander
de visionner une vidéo
pour terminer je
demande une minute supplémentaire de
votre temps c'est une vidéo que le
souhaitons vous montrer
pour que vous puissiez vous voir
l'étendue
des dégâts causés par un peuple et un
pays qui reste impuni
il est impossible que vous veniez vous
voir ce qu'il se passe dans votre pays
directement j'aimerais donc que vous
voyez ce qu'il se passe à travers cette
vidéo merci beaucoup